last week I had the chance to do
something very unique ten days ago I
think bleep was ten days ago
I got a call from first lady Michelle
Obama's office she was going to visit
our troops at the Al Udeid Air Force
Base in the Middle Eastern country of
Qatar what actually that's called Qatar
as part of her joining forces initiative
very cool program and she invited me to
come along to put on a show so I got to
fly with the first lady on a 16-hour
flight
I brought some great performers along
the hilarious John Mulaney incredible
singer Grace Potter two amazing
stand-ups Laurie Kilmartin and Brian
Kiley so we did a show it was a lot of
fun for the troops there the day after
the show I got a tour of the base and I
got to visit some of the specialized
military units and here's the deal we're
gonna put all the footage we shot from
that whole experience together for a
special episode that'll be coming out
sometime soon tonight I thought I'd give
you just a taste of the trip and what we
experienced it's a little tiny I'd like
to invite my friend one of your biggest
fans to the stage the one and only Conan
O'Brien
[Applause]
one down 17 to go I think our sexual
energy shorted out the phone that's cool
thank you so much thank you sir I've
done stupid things in 22 years in
television but this is maybe at the top
of the list
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
why question why did seeing that happen
to me bring you so much joy people like
damn fine hubby anyway we have a lot of
moments like that and that'll be coming
out soon
quickly huge thanks to the first lady
for making that all possible for bring
to every branch that base has just about
every branch of the military serving
there and I think just about every
single branch there's even one guy from
the Coast Guard there in the middle of
the desert we don't know why he's being
punished but they were absolutely
incredible people to meet and so our
huge thanks to them
[Applause]